[Applause]
[Music]
let's start with a question
it's Radomir Putin on the right or on
the left I know I know the answer might
seem obvious but think about it for a
moment
on one hand Putin's style has many
elements we would define as conservative
starting with his anti LGBT rights
gender and his ultra nationalistic
rhetoric
[Music]
but on the other hand he has many
qualities that would make a guy like
Jeremy Corbyn happy Russia is one of the
few countries that continues to support
nicolas maduro the communist dictator of
venezuela and his economic policy is far
from friendly to the free market even as
some left-wing artists like Oliver Stone
who would openly praise him anyway
regardless of where you place him on the
political spectrum Putin is one of the
most revered leaders according to his
own citizens
he has been ruling his country for 20
years and he still receives approval
ratings as high as 80% of course all of
this goes hand-in-hand with repression
of anybody who could challenge him but
facts are facts since the truth is that
the average Russian respects their
leader nevertheless this does seem to be
changing elections embarrassed the
Kremlin the ruling party loses half of
its Moscow's City Council seats
I know I know in a country like Russia
municipal elections aren't really that
important but they do show us that
something is beginning to change all of
a sudden Putin's party United Russia has
turned into a toxic brand its candidates
they no longer brag about their
membership but not only that if you've
been following visual politic for a
while you might remember a video we made
a year ago where we spoke about an
activist called Alexei Navalny we said
Navalny was the candidate with the
biggest chance of challenging Putin and
these latest elections proved us right
remember his name because he is certain
to generate a lots of headlines in the
future and rather the last time I gave
you a tip like this was when I predicted
the winner of the Nobel Prize some
months before Adi Ahmed actually won the
award so the question today is are we
witnessing the beginning of the end of
Putin why are so many Russians rejecting
that once revered leader one is changing
in Russia well today we're going to
answer these questions but before we do
let's take a look back at the history
a legend was born the year 1998 will
always be remembered because it was the
year Britney Spears released her first
super hit but this was not the only
tragedy that year while everyone was
suffering through hit me baby one more
time
Russians were suffering a world class
crisis out of nowhere international
investors were suddenly leaving the
country in droves and when investors
leave a country what will they do well
they quickly dumped that country's
currency in exchange for the currency of
the country where they want to reinvest
their money whether that's u.s. dollars
pound sterling etc this means that all
of a sudden everybody was selling rubles
and nobody wanted to buy them so what
happens in that case well obviously the
value of the currency drops like a rock
and so Russia underwent one of its
biggest devaluations ever from one day
to the next all the money Russian said
was worth half of what it used to be and
yes a good share of the blame should be
pins on the Russian presidents of the
time Boris Yeltsin Yeltsin was the
leader responsible for making the
transition from communism to capitalism
in Russia now without getting into
details a let's just say that even
Britney Spears would have done a better
job
unlike the Czech Republic or Poland
Russia sold their state-owned companies
to oligarchs this means that instead of
creating an environment where innovation
was encouraged the government just lived
on the only valuable thing they already
had to export yep
you guessed it of course I'm talking
about dinosaur juice
[Music]
in this regard poor Boris Yeltsin was
very unlucky well why
during the 1990s crude oil prices were
very low so it was only a matter of time
before the Russian economy would go down
the drain and this is exactly what
happened in 1998 Russia suffered from a
massive devaluation and a year later
Yeltsin had to resign with his
popularity hitting rock bottom and this
is when the man came into the picture
yes we're talking about the awesome the
unique the legendary resigns naming
Putin as Acting President to run in
March election having no political party
to back him Putin decided to run for
election as an independence and believe
me this was the best introduction to the
voting public he could have had liberal
parties have disappointed the Russians
so at the communist party before them
Putin promised one thing and one thing
only stability to make sure that Russia
could have no more ugly surprises no
Chechen terrorism no currency
devaluations
no sudden recessions
[Applause]
and believe me back in 2000 this message
was even more of a hiss than oops I did
it again in fact while Britney Spears
was collecting platinum records Putin
won a landslide victory in his very
first elections with 53 percent of the
vote the next candidate on the list the
Communists won secured just 30 percent
and that's how Putin the legend was born
after that Putin created his own party
United Russia that was a merger between
two other large parties neither of which
at any specific ideology so yes unlike
Yeltsin's failed liberalism into the
harshness of Soviet Communism Putin
promised prosperity and stability so the
question is has he delivered well let's
take a look history repeats as soon as
Putin set foot in the Kremlin oil prices
skyrocketed all of a sudden the
government was making money like there
is no tomorrow
thanks to this Russia was able to lower
their tax rates to fiscal haven levels
today Russians pay a flat income tax of
just 13% then the government was still
making a lot of money from the oil
companies this income allowed Putin to
build roads skyscrapers and hospitals
on the face of it Moscow didn't seem to
have any reason to end the New York in
the average Russian saw how their
standard of living was also improving
there any problem the problem was that
instead of modernizing the economy
Russia remained essentially as it was
traded one elite group of corrupt
oligarchs for another elite group of
corrupt oligarchs today oil and gas
still account for 70% of Russian exports
in fact if you ever heard of a Russian
company that sells something other than
oil or gas showing us struggling so what
happens when you rely so much on one
commodity well this is what happens
economic and political headwinds are
battering Russia whose currency has been
weakened by the free falling oil price
and Western sanctions exactly once again
as soon as the oil prices dropped the
Russian economy fell apart
add to this the invasion of Crimea and
the subsequent economic sanctions and
you have the perfect storm it was the
case of DejaVu of the events of 1998 and
what happens when the international
investors fly away are once again in
2014 the currency was devalued because
everybody was selling but nobody was
buying so that same year the value of
the ruble hubbed in only five months the
average Russian saw how basic food items
such as breads or a humble cabbage
doubled in price and I know what you're
thinking now in such a terrible economic
crisis Putin's popularity must have
plummeted as low as britney Spears's
right well no actually wrong in fact the
opposite is true Putin's popularity kept
growing and this happened for two
reasons on the one hand the Kremlin
increased their propaganda on the other
hands who didn't made sure nobody
absolutely nobody could challenge him
1,400 arrested in opposition election
protests in Moscow
unless submitted this strategy has
worked for years until very recently
Putin's opposition was very weak and
very fractious it was a nuclear ideology
and nuclear leadership until now and now
is when we're going to introduce Alexei
Navalny again his name should sound
familiar if you've been following visual
politic for a while and you don't miss
any of our episodes which is what you
should do so back to our story mizuna
varney is a former lawyer who created an
anti-corruption platform his YouTube
channel has more than three million
subscribers and this is significant
given that Russian is a lot less widely
spoken than English and that Russia is
no country for political dissidents of
course Navalny himself was not allowed
to run for president and has spent more
time in jail than Britney Spears again I
guess but despite all of that
Navalny still holds enormous sway on
elections he just needed one course to
galvanize discontent among Russians
something else apart from corruption and
he found this cause in the raising of
the retirement age all vani calls for
mass rallies against pension reform so
some of you might be wondering are these
protests important can they really have
an impact election wise well let's take
a closer look country without ideologies
in the latest rounds of elections we
have seen how lots of liberals that
celebrated the fall of the Iron Curtain
have ended up voting for the Communists
for the first time in their lives and
while be wondering what has it even
possible while the truth is that in
today's Russia the land of Leninism
ideologies have basically died out there
is only putinism and all the rest in
these latest municipal elections all the
candidates that didn't belong to United
Russia were rejected by the electoral
committee and all of the protests were
repressed by the police nevertheless
unlike in the past the story had a very
different ending
Russian officials tried to frame Evon
goal enough instead they made him a hero
basically Ivan Golan oov is a journalist
who is researching corruption scandals
within the government as is often the
case in this country police found drugs
in his apartment
this is Russia after all you know you
start investigating PETA and drugs
appear in your apartment tomorrow
something like that
now these tactics they used to work in
the past but not with godunov protests
continued and the russian police have to
free golan off in fact support for
Putin's party fell to such a low level
that the candidates for Moscow City Hall
to make a drastic decision Russia United
candidates contested independence and
muff Scout polls however this hasn't
helped much Alexei Navalny presented a
list with all those fake independent
candidates but that's not all we said
earlier that opposition to Putin has
always been fractured right Novotny
couldn't even run for elections and he
has been sent to jail again nevertheless
despite all these obstacles this man has
managed to convince his followers to do
something very important with smart
voting strategy Russian opposition takes
aim of Putin's party of crooks and
thieves basically this smart voting plan
meant voting for whoever had the
greatest chance of defeating Putin's
candidates
no matter the ideology the values or the
party if you live in a district where
the Communist candidate has a strong
chance against Putin's candidate go and
vote to him anything is better than
United Russia literally anything and
this explains the good outcome that the
Communists have had this year in the
Moscow elections they went from having
five seats in City Hall to 13 in 2019
this means almost three times more seats
now this doesn't mean that all of a
sudden Muscovites have become communist
this just means they voted for whichever
candidate was not Putin and this is how
it played out
smart vote protests in Russia the deal
Putin's party of blow in the elections
we still can't say that this is the end
of putinism in fact Putin's party will
remain in power at Moscow city hall that
this is the first time Putin has
experienced some sort of defeat at the
elections what's more this is the first
time a rival political leader has been
able to look Putin in the face
in case you missed it Alexey Navalny and
I know what you're gonna say now here we
go again the guys from visual politic
with their free-market bias making
propaganda in favor of the Diwali guy
the reality is with far from celebrating
about his victory as we said a year ago
Navalny is not the type of politician we
would normally support a visual politic
first of all he's just another ultra
nationalist who has been very vocal
against immigration which is something
we usually like on this channel so far
he hasn't done or said anything that
proves he is the free market champion
that many people want to believe he is
but as you know by now here on visual
politic we analyze and we tell you
what's happening not what we wish would
happen and what is happening now is that
a man despite being in jail has been
able to convince millions of Russians to
make a protest vote so now the question
is over to you we witnessing the
beginning of the ends well we seen a
valley challenge Putin anytime soon and
if he were to win would we see just more
of the same or would he become a new
Putin please leave your answer in the
comment section below and also don't
forget to visit reconsider media.com the
podcast that provided the vocals in this
episode that were not mine also don't
forget we publish brand new videos every
week so subscribe to visual politic and
hit that Bell button so you don't miss
any posts if you like this video give us
a thumbs up and as always I'll see you
next time if you want to learn more
about politics and world affairs and
here's some more of my lovely voice come
check out the reconsidered podcast where
we don't do the thinking for you find
reconsider @ww re consider mediacom or
on Apple or Google Play or your favorite
podcasters
[Music]